I'm really sorry this doesn't fit our
model here at sh-shh I mean armed
security mushrooms really how do you
expect that to work
khmer the catio you won't regret this I
mean look at this mushroom it has a
little cop hat I mean I'm timid ated
look fungi fern you got your start here
shhh and I respect you but my answer is
No
ah it's a on and amethyst scum in third
was just leaving
sit down you two
what is it commander starting earlier
today I'm afraid we're reports of a
hawthorn hipsters on the outskirts of
town making some kind of huge bonfire
raising quite a ruckus out there get on
it to you to show a thing commander
I don't get it why is the commander so
upset about a bonfire I mean sure it's
annoying but why get us involved don't
you get it
cadmium is worried about all the
particulate matter and given up by the
bonfire
you know particulate matter it's a
mixture of tiny solid particles and
liquid droplets found in the atmosphere
it can also be known as particle
pollution so little particles get the
air so what well sometimes the particles
are just soil or dust
other times organic chemicals and metals
can become airborne consider this the
Hawthorn hipster is bringing something
out there when she likes the fire smoke
is giving off that smoke will contain
tiny particles of whatever chemicals
were in the fire so if the chemical is
highly toxic then it's getting into the
air then we better get right let's go so
how do all these particles get in the
air anyway well human activities like
construction mining processing metals or
stones or combustion can release
particles heck busting like bonfires or
burning fuel to make your car run No
yes burning fossil fuels will release
particles in the air that's why the
agency gives us these cars that run on
kale it's not just human activity though
pollen sea salt or dusty bone around
from just the wind or wildfires and
volcanic activity can release massive
amounts of particles near naturally
volcanic activity like that time with a
giant chicken in the theme song yeah
they never show the coolest parts man
things on big record label garbage hey
Hawthorn hipster knock it off
by the authority given to us by sath we
order you to cease emesis you're being a
major source of pollution right now
really how is this any worse than the
noise pollution caused by Taylan drift
and her papi mainstream sound you should
be thanking me well actually we're more
concerned with all the particulate
matter you're releasing into the air
those albums are covered in plastic and
all the chemicals in them and the wood
are thrown into the air through that
smoke so I'm sending tailing riffs
terrible music into the sky where it
can't hurt anyone anymore see that's
where you're wrong
hipster all those chemicals going into
the air could make people way more ill
than country pop fusion music depending
on the kind of particulate matter and
the level exposure people who breathe in
the smoke could have exaggerated
respiratory symptoms like coughing or
difficult meeting aggravated asthma
decreased lung functions irregular
heartbeat non-fatal heart attacks or
premature death if that person has a
heart or lung disease clearly you've
never heard these songs and this fire is
particularly bad because of the plastic
some particles are called primary
particles this matter is directly
released from the source this could
include dust or ash that's coming from
this fire what we're more concerned with
right now are the secondary particles
from your fire those chemicals in the
plastic are forming secondary particles
these are particles that formed from
chemical reactions in the atmosphere
secondary particles are the majority of
particulate matter in the US and are
commonly released by power plants in
automobiles and you Hawthorne hipster
you still don't get it do you I'm
burdened with a glorious purpose I'm
freeing us from corporate trends and
she's not getting it nope we're going to
need one of those point backgrounds for
educational things to happen on oh I
love those this twist reminds me of my
soul wait are you hipster or email
you've got to keep your writing
consistent okay - look this is the human
hair to us they seem very thin but my
particulate matter scale it's pretty big
one human hair is about 50 to 70
micrometers in diameter here's the whole
piece of particulate matter this could
represent dust or pollen it's about 10
my comrades and Diane
that's pretty tiny dusty Paulette they
sold out after their first album you're
going to have a very rich career as a
barista so if that particle is only
about 10 micrometers in diameter that
means we could stretch five of them
across what human hair exactly now check
this particle out yeah I can't see that
at all it is pretty hard to see this
kind of particulate matter represents
metals organic compounds or particles
form from combustion like the chemicals
coming out of your burning plastic so
how many micrometers is that one this is
only 2.5 my convers in diameter that's
so small that fourth one could fit
across the diameter of one of our 10
micrometer particles well if these
particles are so tiny why would they
cause health problems shouldn't they
just slip right through our bodies you
might think that but the particles
ranging from 2.5 to 10 micrometers are
the most dangerous types of particle
pollution in fact particles that are 2
point 5 to 10 micrometers in diameter
our particulate solution is to find us I
would guess that's because that 10
micrometer particles like pollen are
small enough to get in your lungs and
aggravate allergies yeah and the
smallest particles are the most
dangerous because they're small enough
to get into your blood vessels that's
what some major concerns can happen hey
why is it foggy in here fog is so
mainstream so particular pollution is
not just a health concern it also
contributes to reduced visibility at
Hays what's that thing that's a carbon
monoxide molecule it's an incredibly
tiny little molecule that can cause big
problem when you burn plastics fossil
fuels would run a car smoke tobacco you
produce carbon monoxide well it sounds
like it's already everywhere sell out it
is carbon dioxide is was commonly found
in car exhaust but it can also be found
in homes gas Rises chimneys or
malfunctioning appliances the bigger
problem is what carbon monoxide does in
your body since carbon dioxide is so
small I can get your blood carbon
dioxide happens to attach well to your
red blood cells this converts that
chemical that carries oxygen in your
blood
Boban and converts it into a chemical
called car box so I was listening to
hemoglobin back when it was just glowing
you have to be making this stuff up
right without hemoglobin to carry oxygen
to your body in the experience headaches
dizziness fatigue chest pain difficulty
breathing memory loss a flu-like
symptoms in the short-term however if
you're explosive too much of it you can
develop heart disease damage your
nervous system go into a coma or even
die okay I have to admit that's kind of
scary I'll make sure my fire doesn't
release any carbon monoxide that's the
thing since carbon monoxide is colorless
and odorless you won't even notice it's
around what how can I avoid it well to
start make sure that never leave your
car in a garage with authority does the
carbon dioxide can build up also make
sure to get your exhaust system
regularly checked to prevent carbon
monoxide leaks all right so your
suspension looks to have leaked brake
fluid all over the internal drive shaft
which is just completely corroded the
flux capacitor let's go to run you about
$35,000 well that sounds like an honest
assessment is this enough securing your
house is important to never use portable
flameless heaters in the house or burn
anything in an area that is invented you
can also install a carbon monoxide
detector in your house to warn you
unsafe levels remember it's just like a
smoke alarm it needs to have its
batteries replaced and regularity
you can also make sure your fireplace is
well vented and clean
evening governor you haven't seen a
practically perfect lady come through
yeah not without violating the copyright
jeez it's not just carbon monoxide
either
burnings can also release nitrogen
oxides these chemicals can come in
contact with rain and become acid rain
acid rain can change the chemistry of
our environment and affect our health or
you could be releasing sulfur dioxide it
smells awful and it makes you feel like
you're suffocating not only is it gross
to burn your skin and eyes cause
respiratory irritation and who knows
what other effects the chemicals you're
releasing could have
all right time to put that fire out whoa
what did the air here I suddenly feel
like I'm 15 and it's really hard dad's
on the tractor and the board doesn't
like me why won't it go to the dance
with me
15:15 tough huh okay I'll put it out
I'll put it out
I'm glad we could solve this situation
without tempers flare II I don't get
paid enough for this hey come on we need
to work on our witty
agent banter
now gosh hey we need to make a quick
stop before we get back to headquarters
I keep telling you that's not a farmers
market it's a pet store not not that I
forgot my ID way to go to my apartment
your apartment as an for your apartment
relax it'll be fine
look I just remember the holiday party a
few years back I took care of the Badger
you'll see it's no problem
well this place is a reality show
waiting to happen
hey I don't judge you for that perm 1993
called wants its hairstyle back
hello sprinkles hello mister giggles I
love goody falafel hello dr. cutesy hugs
holder PhD at cuddles
hello stripes the tiger okays stripes is
definitely a record that your record
just hurry up and find your ID don't
worry it's right here underneath by
dinner from Tuesday it's Friday
oh and you've never had seriously
absolute hazard
what do you mean I'm not burning
anything in here how is there
particulate matter
not all particulate matter is chemical a
huge amount of particulate matter comes
from a biological or living origin oh
sure like pollen I know all about that
you do heal my allergies are crazy bad
pollen is the male reproductive cell in
a plants many trees release billions of
pollen grains to fertilize other trees
and form seeds pollen can be carried by
insects or other pollinating animals
between plants this polit is usually
used by flowering plants it doesn't
create a lot of problems for humans
other plants use the wind to carry
pollen those plants are the problem this
pollen can aggravate symptoms of hay
fever or asthma this impacts about 25%
of the population in the US Hollan comes
in the air are highest in the early
morning hours between 5 and 10 a.m.
dry when the hot days are in deal time
for pollen to be released so watch out
if you know this impacts you you think
that's why I don't have any plants in
here okay but you still have some major
particulate matter sources haven't you
noticed all those green and white fuzzy
patches all over your apartment oh you
mean the stubble patches up my walls
those are double patches they're mold
fungus
that ah come on I can fungus hurt
anybody the word funds right in it oh
gosh okay
similar to plants fungi have
reproductive cells called spores like
pollen fungal spores can be carried by
the wind and insects or even in water
in fact fungal spores are more common in
the atmosphere in the pollen but get
spores cause the same problems as pollen
they sure can
spores can cause allergen side-effects
like sneezing runny nose mucus
production cough congestion
Eirik headache wheezing asthma or other
illnesses like asthma well great I'm not
done yet the worst bit is that fungi
release chemicals called mycotoxins when
they break down their food
these mycotoxins can also get on spores
before they enter your body in your body
micro toxins can cause infections some
of these micro toxins can cause cancer
asthma like illnesses and some are even
fatal that okay give me the ball give me
the ball I'm not done yet
we still need to talk about those oh not
my precious is not just the cats it's
also that nasty dust all over this place
your dirty clothes
these sheets you probably haven't
changed since no lo what about them
they're only purging dust mites dusts
mites
here look dust mites these little guys
are microscopic arachnids the relatives
of spiders and ticks they feed on the
flakes of skin that people with animals
shed all the Tigers get a life guys well
we do need them all though has the stuff
we just sit around and we'd be waiting
in dead skin but we don't need to
provide them with an international house
and detritus like you have there means
dust mites leave behind that the main
cause of dust allergies and people and
they're found everywhere mattresses
pillows bed linens carpets draperies
upholstered furniture even stuffed toys
ok fungal spores a dust mites this place
is literally filled with particulate
matter how can I fix it well for the
mites we need to wash your stuff you
should be washing your sheets we clean
water above 130 degrees Fahrenheit to
take care of the lights also make sure
that all this dust is clean vacuum our
ability to keep the dust and cat hair
from collecting for the spores make sure
you have all the airs in your apartment
well ventilated to prevent moisture I
would also suggest that you maybe start
wrapping your food and like you lose the
fridge instead of the floor however we
already have mold growing on walls we
need to clean up this stuff with bleach
like five or six of these much better we
better get back to headquarters quick
the commander is gonna be steep
hey Steve
wait amethyst this isn't hey wait
so so then we gotta stop burning the
records because this guy was singing
songs about being a 15 year old girl was
so hard commander
look he sensitive about that new hair
piece be nice
that's not awake okay now you're just
trying to oversell it
no what is the best room hmm you're
right
oh my gosh this green baize must be
sports
they're everywhere okay what are we
gonna do it looks like the spores are
coming out of the mess I'll go look for
the source you take care of the
commander's office
well these must be military-grade of us
there must to go east
keep going let's do this
ignore me will he scoff at my ideas well
frankly commander cadmium I find you to
be a spa
the gigs up fungi 400 fun guy burn all
like fungi oh my gosh that makes so much
sense now it's too late amethyst
I've already take it over you are saying
for protecting the superheated humans of
the dangers a particulate matter both
chemical and organic I'm about to to to
level eight agents now you get to know
Phil still alive